Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier!
and welcome to Bendy and the Ink Machine, Chapter two.
Now, I wanna apologize first about this late video
I know things got off to a bad start today
I had, like, my computer to just explode on me
Uh, and then I had to go to a meeting and then I had to record with Bob, Wade and Jack,
And so I only JUST now was able to record,
which is, like, an hour before you see this video.
But either way this game came out, I'm ready to play it
And I know the last one left off with Bendy, chasing you
after you turned on *gurgle* the Ink Machine...
*Creepy Music*
Game narration : "Oh my head."
...Owie
"...What happened?"
I don't know
You got hit in the head by Goofy!
:D
HELL yeah I get the axe, still!
HYAHH! HAYAHH! (Link? :D)
Oh what happens if you didn't pick up the axe? (Idk)
Would you just go on your daily life
and look at this horrible monstrosity? Oh my god. D':
Is that from the Ink Machine? Eugh.
Alright! Ohh yeah I walked in here and then I got knocked out
but two of the- oh my god its Chapter Two so
two of these symbols are activated.
HIIIYAH! HEEYAH! Okay
So anyway. HELLO? Is-
*Plank suicides*
Okay I didn't actually expect an answer from that!
That was more of a general "Hello?"
Just announcing my presence.
Rhetorical "hello".
*mumbling* Just like all my "hello"s. :')
"He will set us free."
Will he do that? Is this a sacrifice to him?
Also what is that?
Is it a bowl of eggs or is it a bowl of bones???
Game Narration : "How did this place get so big?"
*In response* I don't know.
How did this place get so INKY?
Sammy Lawrence : "He appears from the shadows"
"to rain his sweet blessings upon me."
I don't think thats good.
Sammy Lawrence : "The figure of ink that shines in the"
"darkness."
Nah.
"I see you, my savior. I pray you hear me."
Uh-huh
"Those old songs... Yes, I still sing them."
"For I know you are coming to save me."
"And I will be swept into you final,"
"loving embrace."
NOO!
"But, love requires sacrifice."
"Can I get an amen?"
NO! I refuse! Absolutely not, Sammy!
Sammy Lawrence : "I said..."
"Can I get an amen?" WOAH.
That was not my voice...
D:
Was that my voice?
WHO SAID THAT?
WHO THE HELL *swing* SAID THAT TO ME?
Was it you, Bendy?
I will not give you an amen with all these
satanic symbols!
You're the savior of DICK! >:c
Thats what you are.
*Manly hiyah* Woah. Didn't know that worked.
*Another one* Okie, that didn't work...
Ugh! Ughhh!
It's his sweet embrace all over the floor!
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
God damn it Bendy!
Clean up after yourself. *Manly swing*
h-hiyah!
Game Narration : "Hello! Excuse me! Can you help me! Hello?"
Hoi- Hi! I missed that, I'm sorry! Hello?
What were you carrying?
Game Narration : "Where the hell did he go?"
I didn't even look I was too busy chip choppin!
Now I feel like an asshole! D:<
...Ooh. What's that?
Why does BENDY have bacon soup?
Eugh.
EUGhhh
Alrighty then.
Hmm..
Shhhhhould there be?
Redirect power to the gate, find three switches, OKAY!
I got my eyes OPEN this time except for this
board is gonna GET IT!
And then YOU'RE gonna get it whoever's out there!
Same with this board!
*lots of swiggity swinging noises* Okay.
So there should be switches around here but
I don't recall seeing any switches on the way I-
*realization* OH, I did!
I did see switches! Oh, so we're gonna go on another
hunt, are we?~
Well I got one! (yay!)
Gooood for me! Oh shit-
I ate that.
I don't know if that was a *picks up cans*
Is this a good idea? *Banjo plays*
Okay I'm a musical genius but what's the point of that??
*Swing and scream*
There better not be a switch hiding behind beside no board!
Okay.
I got a bad feeling about eating that bacon soup
because I think that was about to give me some health back
but I don't know why I need it unless there was gonna
some sorta monster that was gonna be hurting me
because that's the only thing that I can imagine for the need to eat
soup is to get health back unless its just all ink
inside that bottle and then that's no good.
Oh yes, rain down on upon
me your blessing!~
*swing* Can I axe the shit outta you?
:D
HIIYAH!
HOhohHOhoHOHohoHOhhoOOOA! (Santa is that you?)
Now I'm the one with power! Maybe...
What happens if I eat all this ink? *Axes Bendy cutout*
Take some of that, biaattch! >:D
I can't eat- Oh yes I can!
Glug, glug, glug! Oh thank you!
There's another one! GLUUUG!
Seems a little greedy for me to be eating all this soup
by myself but what else am I gonna do?
I'm lonely :'))
Glug! Okay, that's all that there!
Glug glug! I got it all!
Inside my bel- HEYA! *Axes again*
Don't do that to me okay?
*Swing'n'scream* Okay.
Huh? Ooooh, fuck you HEEYAH! Well that's how it's gonna be.
Hup bup!
Mhhhm! Huh!
I'm gonna do a 360 whirlwind!
Haaah-boosky!
Yaaah-boosky!
360 NO-SCOPE!
boink!
Huuuh! Can I do a 720, am I sick enough?
HUUUH! I think I made it. I think I nailed that one;
Ohhh! I see you! Wow, you are hard to find.
Good god!
Man, they really hide these things obscurely in this game.
I don't know why they did the same thing with the other
items that I had to find in the last game
but at least its only three of these.
I was wandering around for a long time last time.
But let's carry on!
I've got things to axe in the face!
..Hello??
...Goofy???~
Alrighty then.
Hi- Oohhh!
...Hiiii?
Who in hell in you are?
Hiya! Hiyo! Hee hah!
360! Swahp-- Missed
:'(
...Nailed it.
Got it. :D
Hello?
I'm in the Music Department?
That sounds delightful and happy and fun!
Why wouldn't I like that?
Look at how happy Bendy is in the rain and ink c:
It's raining ink... Don't know why...
*Swingy* The lighter side of hell.
WELL, you know-
Woah I didn't expect that to open, hello!
Hell-o~ Oh boi! Oh boi! OH BOI!
Ohhhh BbOoiii
Hello.
Susie Campell : "This may only be my second month working for Joey Drew, but"
Susie Campell : "This may only be my second month working for Joey Drew but," Uhuh.
"I can already tell, I'm gonna love it here!"
"People really seem to enjoy my Alice Angel voice."
Mmm.
"Sammy says she may be as popular as Bendy some day."
Sureee.
"These past few weeks I have voice everything"
"from talking chairs to dancing chickens."
"But this is the first character I really felt a"
"connection with, like she's a part of me."
"Alice and I, we are going places."
Are you gonna go to the places where
you're being worshipped and sacrificed too because
that's where Bendy's at.
*piano plays*
I'm a GENIUS! :D
Okay alright then.
That didn't do me any service.
So I'm guessing what I'm gonna have to do
is I'm gonna have to come back here and then I'm
gonna collect all these musical pieces.
*drum* Thumpity-thumpy! Thummon the demon~~
:3
I don't know they're all called Lighter Side to Hell.
*violin*
That's a little ominous.
Okay I'm gonna GO NOW!
I'm gonna go awaaay.
I wanna...
I wanna screw myself and have a nice day :)
Take the advice I always give to everybody
Is there a built-in drain to this?
Why would there be a built-in drain into a staircase?!
I mean- I, I wasn't quite an engineer
but I know enough about building standards
that usually, stairways aren't
built with built-in pumps to DRAIN. INK.
And 'cause no standard water pump would be able
to drain ink as well
it'd have to be custom designed for that!
Oh.
I don't know what that did but it didn't do anything.
Alright I'm gonna stop questioning reality here and- Oh!
Alice Angel!~
She sings and she dances.
Why'd she have a devil horn then?
Well that's no good...
Here we gooo!
Boink!
Okay.
Norman Polk :
"Everyday the same strange thing happens."
"I'll be up here in my booth,"
"The band will be swinging,"
Was Bendy always here?
"and suddenly"
"Sammy Lawrence just comes marching in and"
"shuts the whole thing down."
"Tells us all to wait in the hall."
"Then I hear him."
"He starts up my projector, and"
"he dashes from the projector booth"
"and down to the recording studio like the little"
"devil himself was chasing behind."
"Few seconds later, the projector turns off,"
"But Sammy, oh no, he won't come out for a long time."
"This man is weird. Crazy weird."
*projector turns off* Ahh...
"I have half a mind to talk to Mr. Drew about all this." I know what to do!
"I really do."
"But then again, I have to admit."
"Mr. Drew has his own peculiarities."
I'm Mr. Drew aren't I and now what I remember
Okay- Heeey how's it goin' Bendy?
Jesus.
Alright so I gotta run,
From there, awwweee-  HEEEY!!!
WHAT THE FUCK?!?!?!
I DON'T WHAT TO LOOK AT WHAT'S BEHIND ME~!!!
OH GAWD!!!
FUCKING HELL!
D:<
The fuck was that???
What was that? I can't get in here!
Fucking WHAT?!
SHIZUSSS
JESMEEUSSS
Fuck, I can't get in there.
What was that? Okay so there's
Jesu- Oh HI.
HELLO.
You're NEW. (mark is clearly still traumatized)
How long have YOU been there?
WELL you're not down here anymore I guess.
Is he in there?
Fuck.
OH HI.
OOOOKAY.
That's normal.
I'm gonna beat the shit outta you when I
get my axe in your face. >:(
Fuck off-
FUCK OFF!
Fuck, NOOOO. Don't do it.
Hey, hey, STOP IT.
*swing* STOP IT.
AY! Fucking STOP IT.
Stop it! sToP EW.
God. You're so... fuckin' weird.
STOP. Stop I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die.
Don't.
I don't- ah, fuck you.
FUCK YOU.
OH YEAH, OH YEAH.
Can't handle MMME.
*ominous whirring*
God if only I had more soup to drink- wait there's
more of them down there!
What the hell's happening?
alright I'm gonna go back down again, apparently.
Cuz there's something- Oooh.
Sammy Lawrence : "So first, Joey installs..." Oops sorry,
I... ran away.
I just wanted to see what was happening.
Oh, the three are up there now.
Oh, okay.
I see how this is.
Okay, I'm going to go listen to the thing apparently
because you guys are being a bunch of assholes.
Sneakin' on ME.
Sammy Lawrence : "...switch right in my office."
Oh.
"People in and out all day."
"Thanks, Joey, just what I needed."
"More distractions."
"These stupid cartoon songs don't write themselves,"
"you know."
Yeah, they don't I don't know what
Sam is doin'. WAIT.
This wasn't here before.
Hello.
Where was this?
*organ*
*swing* BAP!
Okay. "Nooo..."
Oh!
...Hi?
How long have you been there?
...Okay!
LIL WEIRD! Little weird, not gonna lie. Little weird.
Hello Bendy.
"Do not let Joey see this." Okay.
...okay!
Alright...
ooh.
Somethin' wrong's happenin' here.
"Sammy Lawrence Music Department Director"
What?
m- what do you mean that's one hell of a
leak?! You just walk right in!
You open the damn door!
Alrighty then.
Wally Franks : "So I go to get my dustpan from the"
"hall closet the other day"
"and guess what? I can't find my stupid keys."
"It's like they disappeared into thin air or something."
"All I can think of is that they must have fallen"
"into one of the garbage cans as I was making my rounds"
"last week."
"I just hope nobody tells Sammy."
"Because if he finds out I lost my keys again,"
"I'm out of here."
Yeah then why did you record yourself saying it?
And leave it in the middle of the hallway?
"It's time to believe." I don't know what to believe in
anymore. What the fuck was that?
I heard that...
Oh I heard that. Oh I heard that.
So I gotta find something in a garbage can?
Is that what I heard correctly?
So it's gotta be in one of these garbage cans, right?
maybe...
Alright so I guess its time to go a-huntin' again.
HEY! Woah, woah, woah, woah.
Caught you right in the jibbler jabber!
Fucking douche.
What are you doin?
Also why is the ink coming alive because thats something
that shouldn't be happening, Imma get you if you
get... Get outta here.
Oh, think about it.
I'm just backtracking this way because there
were garbage cans over here so
so I just need to make sure it wasn't in
none of deeez.
Oh, got it!
Okay, got itttt.
Hello.
Okay, so I got that.
And that's good. So now I can unlock this
supposed closet and find out whatever's in there.
EVEN THOUGH, supposedly my character has worked here before.
And knows everything about th- GLUG GLUG GLUG
I love me some bacon soup GLUG
Sammy Lawrence :
"Every artistic person needs a sanctuary."
"Joey Drew has his and I got mine."
"To enter, you need only know my favorite song:"
"The banjo playfully plucks."
"The banjo, once again, strums it's melody."
"The violin shudders with a piercing voice."
"The violin again screams."
"Sing my song and my sanctuary will open to you."
Okay, banjo banjo violin violin.
I guessing that suPPOSED to be randomly generated, don't do it don't do it don't do it.
But, with your stupidity you have revealed your secrets to me!
So I think I gotta go up and I gotta start the movie and then
banjo banjo vile vile
And then I'll be good to go.
Then I'll know exactly what I need to do.
OH there's five of you now.
Great!
Greaaat
GRRREEEAAT!
Love that.
Banjo banjo violin, violin.
Okay, where dat banjo?
*banjos twice and violins twice*
AYYYY! I got it!
Open for me!
OPEN! Ooh~
Well that seems... ominous.
I don' think I should do this!
If I'm turning this shit on, that's bad.
Okay good.
No more Ink Machines to turn on here.
Jus-
AAYYY! FUCK you, FUCK YOU, FUCK YOU!!!!!
Alright.
I think that was inappropriate in *mumbles*
*gasp* Fuck! Hi! God damn it.
Fuck off! Ah. Frick, missed that.
EH. Ow. Fuckin OW.
OW. STOP. STOP. STOP! You'd better not.
You better not have...
*ominous music*
NOOO!
NOOOOOOOOO!
FUCK YOU!!!!
Okay! So now,
Hopefully- Ayy!
Fuck off with you. Fuck off with you.
Fuck off with you. Okay.
One at a time please.
One at a time.
Hey! One at a time.
What was that?
Hello. ONE AT A TIME! PLEASE!
ONE AT A TIME!
ehhhhh, BAP!
MMMM, BAP!
OI! Did I bap em? Did I bap 'em good?
Uh, BAP!
How'bout one more? BAP!
yeah. YEAH. Professional BAPPER over here!
Noted MARKIPLIER!
Gonna BAP you into the next century!
Okay, anyway.
We got it, so if I can get through here,
Now to do is NECESSARY BAP you.
Okay. We're good. We're good.
PUMP!
Okay!
What is that?
That the Ink Machine?
Yeah, Ink Machine mark 2?
Uh-oh!
Well, that don't seem good
I don't know why we need that much Ink but
okay, here we go!
Fuck so we just gotta get out of here.
I-I have words about that save system.
but I'll get to that when I get outta here.
Fucking again?! In the back of my skull?!
AGAIN?
Sammy Lawrence : "Rest your head,"
"It's time for bed."
Okay thank you, yeah all right then.
AGAIN.
Again.
Uh-oh
Maybe we would.
We MIGHT!
Okay...
Okay!
OKAy!
You noticed me!
Yeah I've been here before.
Okay...?
I like my body! I don't know why your body is all
blackened.
Uh-huh
Let us NOT!
I-it doesn't need to, thats not a requirement.
Will he hear me screaming?
Maybe!
Alright. BYE!
Nice feet you loser.
Okay so what do I do about this, what do I do?
I see my axe...
I Can't move~!
That is an option!
Okay!
No thank you!
No means NO!
NO MEANS NO!
Oh..
Okay!!
Okay here we go!
Hey! NO. God damn it
DON'T do that to me!
Don't you fucking do that to me!
BAP! BAP! BAP!
BAP!!! FUCKING BAP!
GET BAPPED!
WHY ARE YOU NOT BAPPING???
Fucking hell!
Bap!
BAP!
Aw, FUCK!
HEY! OH MY GOD.
Oh my god, oh my god!
Okay, alright then!
EEEEEEeeeEEEeeHHH
EEH, Okay THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
Ah! I'm still running I think.
I'm still in trouble I think!
Uh oh!
Uh-oh.
I don't think that's a good idea...
Oooh!!
Hello!
Hai Goofy~!
Okay!
BORIS. Also known as;
Huh that was weird.
So anyway, that is the end of Chapter 2
So the save system: if you're gonna kill the player,
don't make them backtrack 20 minutes to get back to where they were.
That's all I'm gonna say about it!
Other than that, this is actually
getting really really
interesting, I like it a LOT.
And there's still a lot of potential
here. Now in this one, there were enemies.
They could use a little more work,
but it was a bit more threatening in this one
and I like that a bit more
than the ambiguous darkness.
But either way, that is all the time that I have for this episode.
I still have, laryngitis. Like I've still been fighting it.
That's what, have been making my voice so weak.
So I've been trying not to strain it but,
Thank you everybody SO much for watching
I'll be back on schedule very soon. And, uh- thanks again!
And as always, I will see YOU in the next video.
Buh-bye!
(Horror outro)
Oooh, Hello... Uh-oh...After credit sequence?!
Or NOT! I guess.
Ok! Bye~~